in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Charles
and Brad Donna are with us hey guys how
are you hey we're fine
welcome welcome were y'all from
Sacramento California wow that's a bit
of a track to Nashville Tennessee yeah
so I'm sure you're getting in some
vacation time while you're doing all
this yeah afterward where's mom she's in
Birmingham oh okay that's pretty close
yeah yeah well thanks for coming by to
your debt-free screen how much have you
paid off seventy three thousand two
hundred dollars I love it and how long
did that take you 20 months Wow and
household income during that time range
we started about 130 ish and we've ended
at about 173 so in 20 months how do you
get a $43,000 household raise a second
job okay the second job what's the
second job I work for a industry that we
basically are a cementery program for
troubled youth okay wow what a good job
that's a great okay that's cool what do
you guys do for a living internet jobs
I've worked for ups the blessing
solutions mm-hmm and I'm a business
analyst for a high-end furnishing
retailer okay good for you guys great
careers great income but $70,000 what
kind of debt was it I call it stupid Stu
we had credit cards private label credit
cards IRS I hate them so on cars cars
you were like normal people yes sir
just just bopping along just being
normal so what happened 20 months ago
you guys cuz you guys got on fireman I
was filing our 2013 taxes mm-hmm and
Charles and I we have a 16 year
difference but we don't live our life
like that every day you know I don't
look at him and say oh my god you're 16
years older than me so
but filing our taxes looking at our
birth dates right on top of each other
seeing that it I got so much anxiety
because I knew all of the we call them
bills I knew the bills we had out there
but it was really debt and to know and
to know that we had we don't have the
same amount of time of working years and
I was just thinking like oh my god I'm
gonna have to wd-40 em duct tape him and
so then what happened once you you see
realize the need and you went oh we got
through something then what happened I I
just started praying and asking God give
us something we had done a program
before with a previous church and it
that really talked about the why you
shouldn't be in debt but we needed the
how to get out we have to you know about
to be college students that was well
that's your wake-up call stand exactly
how we don't pay for that so what you do
you got in the Financial Peace
University or what no with his second
job I just knew that going to the class
every week wouldn't work work yeah
so you were running a sale at the time
on the Total Money Makeover vertical the
audio books oh yeah so it was like $45
we got the audio CDs and my commute is
around an hour okay Selenia time I get
it you're on fire you're informed how'd
you rope Charles into this Dave it
wasn't hard I was you know I was just
looking at what we old as ammo as
opposed to what was coming in and you
know looking around a house we had stuff
so what she was presenting to you is
logical very logical that we got to
clean this mess up and yeah cool good so
you got after it what was the craziest
thing you guys didn't last 20 months to
get out of that where people looked at
you like you lost your mind cuz y'all
been going nuts here this is something
she's my director one of my closest
friends and I told her about my weekly
allowance
being $5.00 a day so it's $25 and she's
like what comes out of that um when we
go out to eat for lunch my eyebrows and
anything else that I want to work hit me
I was it was eat to me it wasn't as you
know it wasn't as difficult just looking
at you know what we had coming in as
opposed to you know what was going on
you got a good shovel but you were in a
pretty good hole yeah hey you just had
to decide we're not gonna do a bunch of
stupid stuff and we're gonna tighten
down to nothing but you did you went to
scorched earth
I mean unit you you you cut the budget
down to nothing here at the numbers it's
you pay off thirty-five thousand bucks a
year forty thousand bucks a year here
that's a lot wait and one of the
question one of the things we ate out a
lot because we both worked a lot that
was one of the things I think three or
four times a week we were eating out
four four four four people yeah it was
part of bucks a pop he squeezes
absolutely yeah so that was one of the
things that we definitely had to cut out
oh yeah you know just kind of you know
tighten the budget a little bit there
you go she put me back in the yard we
had to get rid of the garden service and
he had been fired before I fired him
before and hired a landscaper
we did this so he got rehired you got a
second chance so what is your advice to
people who want to pay off seventy three
thousand dollars or the debt what is the
primary things they need to do I say
commitment you know and togetherness you
know we have to be together we have to
be on the same page and you know
committed actually seeing you know I'm
the free spirit she's nerd and allow
East to do what they need to do she's
very good at the numbers and allow her
to do what she does allow whoever it is
to do what they do you know allowed him
to do what's what's best what works best
but commitment what about you read on um
keeping each other encouraged because
there would be some times and during
some projects at work and I would just
be ready to twist off
if you would just like text me
snowball baby snowball in capital
letters snowball we need to job snow
it's very good when you have older kids
bring them into it they need to know
that they part so did they learn this
stuff what they did okay we didn't then
they're ready for college huh and I got
bounced checks all the way through
college
this one yeah there you go good very
cool
all right what are your ages and names
of the young ladies kaya is 16 mm-hmm
and Kiara is 13 okay cool very cool all
right
it's Charles Andrew Dominik I yeah and
Kyra from Sacramento California
seventy-three thousand dollars paid off
in 20 months making a hundred and
thirty-two 173 count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one
I love it I love it I love it
well done you guys that's the sound of a
family tree being changed right there
very very real very good stuff
Financial Peace University is the class
that people are going through to learn
how to get out of debt hey you guys
before you leave let me tell you redonda
and Charles I'm going to give you a copy
of Chris Hogan's book retire inspired
because the next step in the process
after you've gotten out of debt is now
to build wealth and retire inspired is
your next portion of your journey you're
heroes you've won this round and so now
we've got a now we've got to give get
you going in the next direction so Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired will be our
gift to you for doing your debt-free
screen scream right here in the lobby
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you